I've finally figured it out.
Prince must've been singing about ACID RAIN
that was BLUE.
Because carbonic acid turns litmus paper red…
Blue plus red equals purple.
If you know what I'm singing about up here.
C'mon, raise your hand.
Hello pH-balanced friends, Trace here for
DNews.
If you were to compare environmental issues
to fashion trends—and I mean why wouldn’t
you—then acid rain would be the equivalent
of bell-bottom jeans.
People started talking about it in the 60’s,
then it slowly infiltrated media and pop culture,
and by the mid-1970s’ seemingly everyone
had an opinion on it, but since then, where
did it go?
To understand acid rain you have to understand
"pH" levels.
pH means "power of hydrogen," essentially
it measure the kind of hydrogen in a solution.
It's not super important to understand how
it works, but it ranges from zero to 14 with
zero (battery acid) being the most acidic
and 14 (lye) being super alkaline (or basic):
7 is neutral -- water is 7, milk is 6, sea
water is 9…
A change in even one number is a big deal,
because pH is measured logarithmically, one
number represents a 10-fold change!
Okay, so, acid rain is bad, you guys.
Like really bad.
It toxifies lakes and streams, destroys forests
and threatens entire plant populations.
Acid rain is even harmful to urban environments,
where it eats away at limestone and marble
buildings.
All because its pH is crazy.
I say crazy, because normal rain is acidic,
just a little bit.
As rain falls from they sky, it picks up carbon
dioxide in the air, creating carbonic acid.
This gives natural rain a pH of about 6, just
slightly on the acid side -- similar to urine
or saliva.
Regular rain becomes acid rain when it picks
up not only carbon dioxide, but sulfur dioxide
and nitrogen oxide, which contain much stronger
acids.
These make their way into our atmosphere when
we burn fossil fuels to make energy.
Once natural rain picks up this acid, its
pH can drop as low as 3.
That means that rain that goes from pH 6 to
pH 3 -- it’s 1000 times more acidic!.
Threes are things like citrus, kimchee, or
soda!
The effects of acid rain entirely depend on
where it lands.
For instance if it falls on limestone-rich
soil, it doesn’t have much of an effect
because limestone is naturally alkaline; it
has a pH above 7.
So mixing acidity with a lower pH just neutralizes
it.
In fact, to protect cultivated areas from
acid rain damage, limestone can be added to
soil as a sort-of pH-balancing fertilizer.
Though that's pretty much out of the question
for huge tracts of land in the wilderness.
When acid rain falls on neutral or acidic
soil, or on vegetation, that’s when things
get bad.
Living things have a hard time in acidic environments
because the acid basically kills their growth
enzymes -- fish can't swim in orange juice!
What’s more, hydrogen ions in the acid rain
replace nutrients in the soil like calcium
and magnesium, which are vital for plant growth.
This is why we preserve things in vinegar,
rather than water because the acid in the
vinegar prevents pickles, or kimchi for all
you foodies, from growing mold.
Keep in mind that we’re talking about ecosystems,
so everything is connected.
Once acid rain infiltrates soil, it flows
into streams and lakes, killing marine life.
Even water-dwelling animals that can live
in acidic environments, like frogs, still
end up dying, because the acid kills their
food sources.
This sort of environmental damage stems as
far back as the industrial revolution; however
the public didn’t really catch wind of it
until the 1970’s, after it had already caused
massive damage -- and that's why you heard
about it.
Why you don't anymore, is because in the early
1990’s the US government passed a series
of regulations that dramatically reduced sulfur
dioxide emissions, and acid rain sorta fell
off the radar.
At least in the U.S….
Acid rain is still an issue in China and Russia,
two countries with lots of factories and few
environmental regulations.
China is particularly bad, as it’s coal
contains higher-than-normal-levels of sulfur.
Even parts of eastern Europe, Canada and the
United States still have rainwater that’s
just too acidic.
And even though our rain will likely never
return to a 1960’s level of acidity, the
effects of this environmental disaster will
exist for decades.
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
So acid rain is still a problem, but what
about the hole in the ozone layer?
What ever happened to that?
You can find out in this video here.
Should we do a whole video about pH? That's kinda cool right?
Do you have science questions?
Tell us in the comments, make sure subscribe so you get the answers
and thanks for tuning in to DNews.